you know we always say
if only the young people came out and
voted especially in the midterms look at
what we could do well we have the
numbers 18 to 29 year olds saved the
election last Tuesday there is a really
great explanation from uh John de la
Volpe I hope I'm uh pronouncing that
correctly where de la Volpe explains the
simple math okay High turnout
combined with 63 percent of 18 to 29
year olds voting for Democrats versus 35
percent of that very same group voting
for Republicans gen Z and the younger
Millennials under 30 effectively
canceled out every voter age 65 plus
this is absolutely fascinating and then
when you look at these groups you look
at 18 to 29
and you look at 65 plus 18 to 29 had a
plus three overall contribution to the
vote margin for Democrats and 65 plus
had a minus three overall contribution
for Democrats we always talk about the
older Generations are significantly more
right-leaning and there's just not
enough young people voting to cancel out
or make up for that that is exactly what
that is literally what happened on
November 8th the very uh uh same
three-point contribution that the 65
plus group overall made to Republicans
was eliminated it was zeroed out it was
teared as we might say uh by 18 to 29
year olds who contributed a three-point
margin to Democrats it was their own
future on the line I wish that they
would vote more and it's important to
focus on the fact that it's not
record-breaking numbers necessarily that
may make the difference here it's that
enough young people turned out to vote
in order to undo the significant
right-leaning effect of the 65 plus
group at the end of the day uh 53
percent of eligible voters voted in the
2018 midterms uh in 2022
only 27 percent of those in that
youngest age group voted so consider
that comparison there is so much
Headroom for that youngest group to get
more involved and I know it's so cliche
because we always say look at the math
if that young group got more involved
they could wield so much power and
influence well we are seeing it 18 to 29
year olds canceled out the 65 plus vote
the Red Wave evaporated it will maybe be
a ripple and the amount of Headroom that
that group has to single-handedly decide
elections is incredible we've just got
to engage them we've got to get them
involved make sure you're subscribed to
our YouTube channel very important we're
pushing for 2 million subscribers we
will be live tomorrow night with Trump's
announcement on YouTube twitch and
Facebook hope to see you there